welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hashim azuz and today
on a super Buy and Hannah Jarvis who is
one of the cofounders of haptic recruit
hello thank you so much for joining me
you must fill out the pro now thank you
for joining me and as you know where I
always always like to start mm-hmm
how the hell did you get into
recruitment Hannah Jarvis what happened
Golden Age question so I actually did
law at uni oh yeah did law I didn't find
out very quickly I did not want to be a
lawyer like after the first seminar
really yeah I just like stuck with like
a lot of statue I don't even like
reading it was just like I push you down
that route than your parents yeah but I
also kind of looked at it as like the
golden gates you know ya grew up in like
a very middle-class area I was at all
why don't I be a lawyer and move to the
city and excetera
but it doesn't always work out that way
so I didn't really want to go down the
corporate ladder having to say certain
things to get somewhere or having to do
some things so yeah persevere three
years anyway got the degree moved back
home managed children's therapy center
like a year really a bit random yeah
then my friends were moving to London so
I just kind of like jumped in mm-hmm
where were you born whether you got
Talmud wells okay yeah tell me please
fun well yeah yeah yeah all right isn't
it it's all right yeah it's all right so
yeah so I moved to London and I found
myself in a pyramid scheme okay yeah it
was like basically imagine clipboard
lanyard standing on the streets of
London trying to sell credit cards to
people really yes these hardcore sales
no it was not decent
I got a doner kebab in the face it was
an interesting month of my life like a
did you did you know it was that what
was that I sold as a marketing executive
job considering am a Salesman I can be
sold you very easily really went in and
this woman should I write
yeah sounds great sign me up
nah really I did it for a month and I
hate not being good at something
whereabouts Langan was it it was based
in angel but we went to like all like
the edge edge edge I always I always
give time to people that are doing that
because I just think I just have so much
respect for it but and then oh and then
other I don't they don't close me
because I'm just giving them sometimes
no one speaks to them most the people
that do ad like trying to sign him up
for charities which is a good thing yeah
not trying to get your credit rating
your money that must been hard
yeah it was not in keeping with my moral
compass okay
so I kind of said what the hell should I
do next once the Karen obviously living
in London my brother was in recruitment
okay he was in recruitment of like seven
years by that point Wow
yeah moved his way up from like
consultant to manager I think he'd like
a team of 15 or something yeah he was
like don't do it but I was like [ __ ] you
I yeah yeah yeah and then I interviewed
probably at like 15 maybe 20 recruitment
company really I got through to the
final stage every time but I never got
an offer why is that
I don't know then they'll give you to
see that they I think basically I think
when you want to hire a grad you want
someone that's slightly and somewhat
moldable that you can kind of put in a
box and be like follow these processes
and do that yeah and I just I'm just not
that person I'm not any those drive-ins
that person oh okay I'm not I don't
wanna bring the gender thing into it but
okay all of the people that interviewed
me were like old white men I remember
them I remember like one of the CEOs he
was mental he was like tell me why
you're different to every other person
out there like literally like crawling
across the table like losing his mind
yeah and the first woman that
interviewed me like offered me on the
spot really yeah and then I found out
about your staff through my brother
because it's like a sister company or go
to their umbrella group interviewed it
your staff by that point I think I was
just like [ __ ] yeah that's good yeah I
just like calmed down a bit I think and
I was like yeah yeah let's do this
so yeah they offered me Anna and I
joined what did you learn for that
process then beside
obviously there's a lot of men in
recruitment and you're not this multiple
person but like how are these people
selling your recruitment like so you'll
see I had to persevere for that that's a
lot of rejection right yeah I'll see you
just for the streets getting done the
kebabs in your face yeah and you're
getting rejected 20 times yes what made
you want to still get onto did it sound
interesting to you because I probably by
that point had a very sizeable chip on
my shoulder
yeah I wasn't saying other points prove
I've got four brothers so I've always
been competitive
really yeah so by that point I was like
[ __ ] them well yeah so yeah but how do
they say recruitment to that light
how did was the sales pitch yeah how do
they sell it like have autonomy it's
like building your own business within a
business yes I like the idea of working
like the Nordic market okay that was
like the unknown yeah I really like my
manager my manager funny enough was like
very very process driven hmm so I think
because he was one extreme and I was the
other we kind of just like we somehow
found a middle ground yeah
so that obviously I know obviously those
lows it interviews by the time you
decided to own your own stuff but was
there anything that you saw will
recognize that you'd like to know I
actually like this company was it the it
was the Nordic market was it more
interest to you about that it was the
unknown wasn't it
you see unknown like I didn't even I've
never even been to Sweden okay and I was
suddenly just like working in working in
Stockholm Oh what you were there you
were no no I worked in this in this week
okay okay cool so you really like the
idea of that yes interesting yeah like
the industry's like tech gaming hmm both
seem pretty cool I didn't know anything
about those industries so again I had
the opportunity to learn that okay
that's right enough so what was gonna
say so and then you went into the gaming
industry from from day one or not I did
like mostly tech my manager one of his
main clients was King I don't know that
developers a candy crush okay so that
was one of the first placements I did
alright it was like a lead designer at
King okay so that's how I like found out
more about the industry and then it kind
of just like I am okay so how how how
long were you at your stuff like I would
have say two years but I don't
I think it was two years like over one
and a half years really yeah what went
on in the first year a lot I did quite
well in terms of billing what did you
bill I was told why don't we have any
comparison do i I think I did like 220
okay which was in yeah definitely
better me 24k that's definitely good for
your first year for sure as you said in
the market they never you didn't know
anything about in then I think I've got
a message today actually from her I was
asked people if they want if they want
me to go over certain topics for people
yeah and this guy missing me today
saying them about talking about
resilience which you always do but
particularly around people recruiting
into the EU markets because that's what
he does and people around them a fondant
like really tough really why's that I
don't know he just told me that it'd be
interesting to speak to people that are
recruiting to the EU markets and the
challenges that come with that and those
things but I wasn't assay was the fact
that you wasn't recruiting in a UK
market as well and all that so there's a
lot of challenges and a lot of unknown
so that's definitely well played but I
didn't know any different tree mean I
just write for you I didn't start in the
UK market and have those very selling
creep Minh style
I just went it straight into the noisy
markets you you have to adapt the
culture in that's one if that's probably
the main piece of advice I would give
really yeah like Swedish people in the
way that they work and what they want
from someone and like everything else is
completely different see was you just in
the Swedish markets and all was that
what Stockholm that's what we did in the
first year the whole time oh the whole
time yeah okay cool so let's break down
that first year a bit then like what so
obviously you build well so did you dive
straight into like 360 was you did you
get given the phone get some clients or
like I was think I did a couple of
deliveries but I was thinking when I
might I'm visiting my second week really
so I went to Stockholm my second week
kind of just thrown in the deep end yeah
cuz I manager was going anyway so he was
that come with so I was already meeting
clients well that Swedish lookers I know
blonde hair
not natural all right
[Laughter]
she literally lied just straight in the
deep end stop me inside to be fair I
should I think I met a client in the
first couple of weeks just decent to get
an idea of to the businesses that you're
helping them those things yeah I'm gonna
thinkers so if you left it any longer I
would have been like I like that he just
kind of threw me okay cool so okay so
was you did you said was you beat in
quite early on that yeah yeah I can't
exactly remember I first got my client
but from quite early on I liked being
tricks 360 360 I liked having like did
you do anything to learn about the
market that you didn't anything about
besides like how did you dive into
getting sort of acquiring the right
knowledge um YouTube video is a good
place to start
just research really I think we had to
do a presentation on market pretty early
on so it forced me to do like research
enough yeah that's good oh there isn't
yeah people don't okay so that helped
and then obviously a lot of people say
sort of speaking to candidates and stuff
into Candice I think people are scared
to ask questions they like you don't
know anything about this industry you're
never gonna know as much about the
industry as a person you're speaking to
the candidate you're speaking to so you
can just say that I remember just being
like look I'm sorry I do not designer
can you break that down can you explain
that for me yeah okay cool how how did
you find business development then
because that's always a topic that
people allow me to talk about because
that's difficult right it's it's a good
it's an interesting one and you just
make yeah yeah you smashed the phones
but the biggest piece of advice I would
give is creative writing right right
like we've we do it in our training and
haptic now we actually like have like
mass of creative writing like
brainstorming sessions because if you
think about it you've got to your three
ways you can get new clients you've got
on it for networking conferences etc
referrals from current clients or
candidates
you've got the phone just like phoning
or you've got a cold messaging cold
emailing cold messaging or LinkedIn now
personal Brown exactly to separate
yourself you don't they're just going to
delete all those emails that come into
the inbox that are like
I've come across your company and I've
got some openrov right I've read so many
of those yeah exactly the [ __ ]
they're just gonna get deleted yeah I
think thinking outside the box in terms
of your cold messaging approach being a
bit weird being a bit crazy is the way
to go
it gets give me some examples cuz we had
a few to give you some context so had
them a lady called Alicia Tegel yeah and
she thought she'd spoke exactly about
this where she was like look I encourage
my consultants now to be authentic be
unique stand out exactly what we're
talking about so she was like you know
what I'm gonna start sending out some
and peculiar messages so I'll stand out
so she shared this story about basically
she sent an email to a business that
she's been trying to get in with ages or
just the decision-maker just a picture
of a white rhino
yeah just subject rhino and then he came
back was like why sending me this she
was like have you ever seen one of these
before he's like no and then when she
replies have you ever seen one of these
before
there was a candidate towards me about
some stories I'll give you one example
something called haptic bingo haptic
bingo bingo yeah okay so we went on what
is it mukombo something we made our own
bingo card yeah yeah and we basically
taking the piss out of the classic
recruitment terms hmm so you know gonna
create some urgency or whatever it is
he's finding clothes whatever your
perfect candidate whatever it is and
then you have all those classic terms on
the bingo card and then I kind of attach
it or you can send it in the post and
you can be like I promise if we like
when we have a phone call I will not use
any of these terms okay and did you do
that kind of stuff in neuro staff also I
remember my second yeah but I always had
those ideas I was always the one like
okay great this is a way to do something
but why the hell are we doing it
differently so he was always always
reminded to lie
differently yeah so when you use euro
stuff then would you just rely on the
traditional methods to crack on and BD
and get crying with a sprinkle with a
sprinkling of myself really yeah so how
do you trying to stand out through that
then because that's obviously the
challenge right what you're talking
about you have the luxury of doing that
now because you have your own business
but there's many people listening that
may be open to this and they're like
Jesus Christ this is getting really hard
difficult now and I do want apply
different things just so saturate that's
why I'm in life so how did you go about
that and your staff then so I think you
like my second week and your staff might
be I don't know my third whatever I just
made a meetup group in Stockholm really
yeah I was like why don't we doing
meetups why are we doing events I'm
loved like a VR and AR cuz it's when VR
was loads and money was getting pumped
into it I was like why aren't we doing
like events for candidates or just in
general so I made a meetup group and
they told me not to they were like no
Hannah we need to wait we need to get
Authority whatever approval I just did
it and we got like 300 members and like
really and I was I remember having to go
to like Glen it was a head of marketing
there he was like Hannah should have
done that but now we can't go back but
now we're gonna have to do it yeah it
got like a thousand members really the
second biggest VR or something yes and
we start doing events and stuff like
that okay so I guess what you're saying
there is just just be willing to do it
and see what happens I just do it okay
yeah let's talk a bit about cuz I think
and let the other thing is like a lot of
people are going into if not already
there's a lot of businesses that have
been trading than EU markets for a while
but obviously I think it's safe to say
that there's a lot of recruitment
businesses that are looking at EU
markets US markets etc so let's talk
about because you said that you had to
adapt to what what they're what they're
like right so let's talk a bit about
that cuz there will be people listening
that may have to go into straight city
markets were looking to expand into EU
markets so what did you learn through
that journey like what what were the
different nuances that you had to learn
and sort of adapt to from a client and
candidate perspective I think again it's
more about because recruitment has been
established in the UK for so
long there's always the there's already
huge stigmas and huge kind of
expectations about how you should behave
and you can get away with doing like the
more hard sell and everything else in
the UK markets people are just used to
err yeah but in in other European
markets like the Nordic market you can't
do that people just don't appreciate it
if you're trying to push them down the
same path and pushing down certain part
like cold calling them like all hours of
the day really yeah like just be you
need to be much more person and
personable in your approach okay that's
what I really mean ones yeah so so
you're talking when you did get free to
someone you've got a sort of yeah you've
got approached it in the right way so
you don't rub them up the wrong way
basis yeah yeah yeah bring it's
ridiculous how many people I've known
had like massive personalities and then
they sunny pick up the phone to a
candidate and they just turn him to like
a recruitment really that professional
yeah yeah it's bizarre like if you've
got a big personality this is like a
people market user it's gonna get you
places okay and was there any was was
there only like how did they was their
perception of speaking to Hannah he was
like this UK go in London lie and their
ins like Sweden like how did these
people take take that what was a was
that was it sort of was only challenges
around that they would did him over you
Kara career was it pretty sweet that
wasn't actually no was it not no because
you're bringing if you can bring all of
the best bets of UK recruitment like
they're really good had no skills etc
but then be as like personable and
everything else is their local
recruitment firms and honest and just
like yourself then you've got the
perfect combination cool did you meet
handlers or clients yeah already do you
do video calls no no no I used to go
there like probably once every six weeks
really yeah when any [ __ ] doulos
emissions yeah
back-to-back decent yeah that's good so
you know so we didn't quite well
stockholm stockholm yeah really yeah
that's quite cool so anything else that
went on in that that first year that's
worth sharing on talking about Burnley
did
really I don't think I'm made for
contract why I just I I feel like I'm
screwing someone over contract them away
like cuz you're lying you know from what
I gather you have to basically lie about
the kind of salary so you're selling
because you I don't I don't
yeah I just like yeah give me a pound I
can't do this okay so so after euro
stuff you set up haptic yeah company in
between yeah yeah but I thought she
didn't work out so yeah we set up haptic
in November November last year
mhm so how the hell like because a lot
of people will listen to this and thing
while Hannah's done recruitment for what
18 months yeah she's got her own agency
she's doing it with a brother who told
them not to get into recruiting yeah
obviously your brother by this point my
said like what a decade of experience
yeah
so I mean at the end of the day like
obviously the experience helps but it
doesn't mean that you can't deliver for
Kanaks and clients right but was that
how the hell did that happen
like what do you not I mean have you
always wanted to have your own business
or not yeah 50 percent balls I think
most people could do it it's it's just
having the balls to do it really yeah
it's just about taking the like jumping
in the deep end and sinking was it was
this like was it someone your brother
had always wanted to do as well cuz yeah
but my brother's not as much of a risk
taker as me so I need to do do you have
to send him there yeah I need to be like
we're doing this let's do you not I mean
really yeah he's like very good at there
like day to day like all the like
consistent kind of staff and I'm better
at like taking a bigger risk long-term
vision etc so we complement each other
quite well
really and how has it been in business
of your prey it's good initially it was
a bit like this is weird like a dynamic
how did you like it
surely you have to the 9df like draw the
line where it's like right okay we
talked about other than I like the
personal stuff for a bit like me out
there's got to be some sort of shot off
a shot off or you just just
carried on and this of Gris the
relationship as business partners I mean
because I've got three older brothers in
London I hang about with them loads
anyway really yeah they're like from
friends of all their friends so it was
weird to like you know see him in a
social thing and then see ya at work but
we used to it now
more than any conference what are the
name oh god I can't even pretend it does
mean something like the physical touch
I'm not even gonna try I just I like how
it sounds I like how it looks just like
the letters yeah okay cool so let's say
you're so how many monsters at and then
like what nine no hundred mumps is that
us how those months been then what's
been going on what's been going on okay
so yeah we've got we work with a global
candid network but we work we're in four
key hubs
okay Helsinki Bastogne in London okay
and we work with like a particular type
and number of studios studio is a gaming
company okay in each of these hubs okay
they're both like startups and and the
bigger guys
but yeah so we've got established client
bases in each of those hubs we're going
into Berlin soon yeah it's going well
moving well we're just like specialise
in the gaming space at the moment
million so you really nice down
obviously was doing you obviously ended
up dinner anyway when he was employed
yeah we've really niche down you've
identify there is where there's
obviously key places and that's what you
dedicated to and you're based in London
yeah so I guess let's talk this sort of
unpack a bit what you've I'm sure it
like you can't even probably remember
what happened last week but like what
let's talk about like what what you've
learned through this process right
because obviously yeah you've got to
have the balls but and then you've got
you've got to execute so like what's
been going on and what would be what's
been different from being employed Hanan
for euro stuff to now being in business
with your brother because there's a lot
of people listening there and are
thinking about setting up the right
agency or want to or already through
that journey who it's just them at the
moment that haven't had that luxury of
actually doing it with a family member
it's sad you know I mean so let let's
unpack that a bit because I'm sure
there's some things in there
definitely worth talking about so I
think you know I remember starting and I
literally because obviously I didn't
work with more clients yeah in Stockholm
so I remember starting with a laptop and
and a LinkedIn light account and I was
about to just try and get clients in
London never even worked in the UK
market I was like [ __ ] how did it
yeah just starting from nothing
blips your laptop on a phone so people
underestimate so you have no business
plan
no not initially oh cool
yeah I think because the first company
wasn't enough planning so then by the
time I got to haptic yes there wasn't
like a plan and everything gals but when
I first first left euro stuff it was
just a photo yeah okay cool I think yeah
there's a massive difference from
running a recruitment company with a
strong brand you actually knowing your
competitors are and working around that
and knowing where you're going in the
medium to longer term to just placing
people in jobs like there's a massive
difference and I think people
underestimate noting the amount of
commitment that takes in your life but
however your friend's been good none of
them like owned their own companies or
anything they're pretty much all talking
about this last week malicious lie it
because yeah as you said there's a lot
of commitment that people obviously
probably don't obviously if you're gonna
start your own company you know there's
I mean it's like you're gonna have to
[ __ ] pay the bills and end the day so
you know you have to be committed but
obviously the the friends part is
interesting because all of a sudden you
can be lying but I need to work tonight
or whatever then that can start getting
a bit weird of friends probably most
I've always been that person and
switching like people just didn't
understand it you know like me saying no
like no Anthony Cocotte this weekend
dude I'm not going on a week anymore so
yeah it was an adjustment but the end of
the day if they your friends they'll
stick by you and if they're not
okay so one clearly first thing is you
need to really think about the
commitment what's involved and also
there's a lot more to it on the business
side than just well if you if you used
to start if you were to start again I
know you're not even that far a bit
obviously that early on what what would
definitely be like you'll go to
definitely do this first or I'd
definitely make sure I have that in
place or whatever I wouldn't change
anything
because in the company before I
I made a lot of mistakes and I did
something's right and I learned from
that so I'd already had so what do you
learn from that then let's talk about
because people ya know how much of a
sacrifice is gonna take like in general
yeah you've got to be seriously it's
like seriously committed that you want
to do this for the long term Brant brand
is key I think so many recruitment
companies they just have like a website
and you just think they've got that
old-school mentality that are like don't
worry about it place these candidates in
these roles bish bash Bosh money in the
bank that's it no you need to think
about how am I gonna actually separate
myself from the other 8,000 recruitment
companies that start in the UK last year
yeah one of the main things you can do
that is by like your your business and
personal brand yeah so how view of see
besides send them in big cards yeah like
oh so you've learned that that's
interesting so besides obviously when
you speak to people being unique being
yourself and those things right which is
your brand that you own and those things
but so yeah what else have you done
differently than to try and stand out
because a percent the recruitment market
in the UK employ under 10 people so like
that obviously everyone knows it's
saturated and everyone thinks that
they're different but it's exactly what
you said a lot of these people want in
anything really different right so how
have you gone about that then besides
sending Wynnum I hear messages to
clients I see yeah like Brian would
definitely be one
your blogs your podcast yes your events
all of that that's like in in one
bracket how do you prioritize out
because you must be very time poor right
now I categorize my day with like four
things a pipeline sourcing business
development director duties oh let's
talk about that what I just said like
the vlogs the blog's that's under
director duties how do you start your
day let's talk about how you structure
there like that okay there was no one no
instructions like that before so me and
my brother we have like symmetrical day
plans under four categories select
sourcing BD pipeline and directed you do
you have a massive how big of a blank
the blocks the blocks of time anything
between an hour to two hours really
really so there's also it's always like
four categories that you're focusing on
yeah and then we have these different
things that fall into the category yeah
and they change depending on what our
day objectives are weekly objectives or
our monthly objectives really we've got
to be consistently like updating those
yeah so where do you update like how do
you communicate with each other like the
visual thing or is it just a lot of
piece of tech that you use it's just
like something called agenda it's just
like a pretty good like day planner list
thing really yeah so and then the
branding and content side fits into what
category to do to change this director
duties are like operational account yeah
I know that they're gonna get done mine
and I know when they're gonna get done
and I know what's in his list at all
times yeah he knows I'm doing the vlogs
the blogs the events yeah like all of
the other stuff like a training plans
things like that yeah so we separate our
tasks very well and then obviously saw
Singh Bedi that's all standard I like
that have you always done that or did
you like the view that was just a sort
of evolution of it got support Mary's
like actually let's just break down our
day and make it simple yeah it's a lot
of trial and error
really I'm always like I've got an idea
let's try it let's let's do this now and
we've got to this point in we're like a
sickness works really it's been working
well fear hmm decent yes good so how
many of you are there not so there's me
my brother and a guy called Ryan he's
like an ex-professional football oh
really he's hilarious he's like super
competitive
how did you find how did you find
employing your first hire I've also been
interested in it was fine James used to
manage him already yeah James taught
smart yep they've already kind of got
that dynamic yeah yeah but yeah it's
good
it's been good and then we've actually
just hired someone from Stockholm okay
who's in the gaming space so you like
flip them into recruit basically yeah
like how hard would it be for a
recruiter to learn how to be in games
artists and have all the knowledge that
he has but how hard would it be for his
eyes to become real yeah yeah I also
work in insurance and I went into
insurance recruitment definitely I mean
you can have a point in different from
day one aren't you exactly and you're
gonna fully understand your market never
fence I mean he's had his own startup
he's like hired ten people himself
that's how I met him cuz I approached
him to like their first studio in
Stockholm at decent and he's like super
personal he's got all like the perfect
ingredients yeah to be a really good
recruiter I took him on a client meeting
off his first day really cool of that so
I guess and if any but it seems like
obviously a good strategy is to employ
people that you've had some sort of
relationship where we trust the whatever
but did you learn anything through that
or is that being pretty smooth obviously
because that can be a real challenge
right yeah hiring their first person
those things lot of this I'll see you
here quite a lot of advice around if you
can hire people that you know or your
friends or whatever then great but did
you let them looking through that hiring
process or not really really really
fairness what we have tried and that's
what I'm saying like we are at the stage
we'll be trying a few different things
yeah
we've tried like an outsourced like
sourcing company really yes okay yeah
where they light and indirect in like
India or something they're gonna become
so more popular yeah I've spoken to
quite a few yeah my brother he his
friends had like a 15 person recruitment
company in London 10 10 P basically 510
people recently and just kept five for
BD and pipeline really now he outsource
all to this company
so we were like let's try it it will
never be like our like let's talk a bit
more about that if you don't mind yeah
what so what sort of times you get them
to do is it a lot of the grunt work like
this sourcing and and like so what some
of the tiles that they did so we've
literally got like written a sourcing
process perfect step-by-step yeah
because that's what you got to do with
these things obviously that's a bit
trial and error but you've got to make
it as clear as possible to examine able
them to deliver what you want them to
they yeah like the how to describe but
we've got like a chart yeah and they
basically color code which stage they're
at and what they're doing really yeah so
we know so if they go off if they go off
the line like imagine there's a straight
line yeah if we go if they go off the
line for whatever reason they're not
where they should be
why are they there sitting more training
we just got these little systems in
place I like it but so so when so up to
what point would you then get involved
cuz I think that would be something that
people's concern is it's like so if
people if they're going to be trying to
approach people on my behalf I need to
be confident they're they're competent
to do that and they come across in the
right way and those things like well
what point do they get more do they
speak to these candidates or do they
send you a shortlist then you call the
relevant people like when do you get
involved they have the first call they
do the first call and we will always do
another cool really okay yeah of course
but that's interested in because some
some people might not be comfortable
with that some some Indian person call
in no it's just interesting that you've
done that so it's not that it's just
more of like I think if I'm if I'm a
recruiter right now I'm thinking these
people that I've never met before we've
might have been a video called how come
why I'm them calling people that sort of
so I was interested as to when you get
involved you can't just be like okay
guys go and find me candidates yeah to
be like right you're with us now they
work for us full time this is what this
is how we do it this is why we do it
so what as I labeled you to do that was
spent more time on what Abel does to
spend more time on business development
like everybody everything else in the
company hmm
because sourcing obviously takes up the
most time anyway it's been pretty
successful so far obviously far I mean
I'm not gonna lie the first few weeks
were touch-and-go but and you do have to
put the effort into yeah that's the
biggest part isn't that because I read a
lot if you ever come across a guy called
Tim Ferriss he wrote this book called
4-hour workweek and I was a big part
around that on VA s and obviously this
also there it's an outsourced sourcing
solution but a big part is its same sort
of process of if you're hiring a VA
you've got a you've got a really make it
crystal clear as to what they've got to
do what successes it's like there and
what it doesn't nice thing so yeah
you're totally right but would you read
would you recommend it to people then
who because there will be people
listening who might be one-man-band bit
smaller maybe even some recruiters could
benefit from this where they could then
speak to people and certainly got Lert
if we get this outsourced or outsourced
solution right it will enable us to
spend more time on the activities that
are gonna give us the outcomes that we
want yeah I would recommend it but like
I said get your processes great
understand don't just be like I've done
now like yes a two-way relationship yeah
that's exciting
my mentor knows a woman who basically
she just does all the pipeline and
business development herself and she has
19 resources really and she bails 2 mil
a year Wow yeah 2 million a year yeah
yeah well so do you think cuz I think I
think like like listening to you speak
and the way you're approaching things
absolutely absolutely love your energy
and how you're approaching it but I
think if you think about your I don't
use the word naive but like you're so
open to like doing things differently or
triangle do you know I mean so what's
your view then on like and obviously
you're obviously you have a mentor and
you're you're probably known little
bubble just making [ __ ] happen but like
do you think more moral criminal
businesses will do things like you're
doing and outsourcing and all that like
what how do you think that's going to
affect the recruit the day the day to
day recruit you know I mean I think you
know a lot of
Korean companies they work in industries
that are like ever-changing like tech
gaming etc and we have to tell you have
to like move with it
ya can't just be doing stuff like the
old school way anymore yeah it's just
not gonna work in the long term in my
opinion and I think I think generally I
think listen to some of your stories so
far is like you've just been open minded
and I think that that just goes so far
like you're prepared to try different
things and actually well I know I've
been taught this way but how come we've
never thought of it like this I'll try
it this way obviously now have the great
thing behind your own business you can
try these things straight a Rove out and
not speak and all these ideas yeah I
couldn't do anything with them love that
okay cool
all right mentor yeah my speaking about
that a little bit okay you have to say
who it is yeah so how did you because I
have my own mentors and I think more and
more and quite a lot of people off the
back of listening to this have reached
out to people and and those things so
did you reach out to this person to
mentor you or division actually happened
today so I won an award and I was at
your staff Best Newcomer well 220k first
year left so I wasn't even there to pick
it up really yeah brutal I know we went
to I beat there and I literally came in
my suitcase the next day probably just
super hungover and I was like really
[Music]
okay so this person still willing to
mental you are he was one of the judges
okay what did you have to do what did
you have to do though for this award
that like just like you said hebes
so I think there was like short list of
like 10 people and you go there and you
speak to a panel of like six or seven he
was one of the judges okay so he also
goes you got a full dose of Hannah
Jarvis basically yeah I did like a pink
suit
okay they just speak about you know what
I've done the events in Stockholm yeah I
work how I think etc they're why one but
okay so then it just naturally happened
then it seemed like okay that's
interesting well and how long have you
had that sort of cool at mental
relationship when it was a bit more than
when I agree when I set up really really
yeah okay well let's just talk a bit
about that because I think a lot of
people would really benefit from so what
have you go out of it from your
perspective you know like I know the
basics of recruitment at your staff all
the other stuff I've done you know I've
just kind of got to this point but I had
no idea to how to build a recruitment
company
I've only mentored one person mental
someone I'm mental one person Eurostar
already yeah that's totally different to
business yes
so obviously there's there's a lot I've
kind of learned along the way and that I
dunno but there's a ton that I have no
clue about so I think it's being it's
about being able to step back and look
at actually what do you know what don't
you know what your weakness is and then
filling in the gaps and his like what he
could give me was okay this is how you
build a recruitment company successfully
this is how I did it etc and what do you
give him
I don't know the reason I the reason our
site is because that someone could be
listening right now it's like think that
person obviously the great thing about
that which I'm sure you're super
grateful for is that he obviously he saw
you a euro staff and was like [ __ ]
hours his once watch out for whereas
someone right now could be listening in
his in his bedroom yeah and like was
what because it's like these people that
they reach out to they're gonna be time
poor do you know I mean life someone
reached actually now that Hannah I'd
really like you to mentor me it's got to
be a two-way things you know I mean so
you've had that advantage so that's why
I wanted to ask
[Laughter]
that's right enough so it's helped you
on the it's helped you actually what you
said as you recognize sort of the
knowledge that you do have what you
don't have and this person's helped you
I guess guides you along the way of
actually what would your advice be
around this but I've learned those
things yeah this is something that you'd
recommend people if they if they have
the cash do you speak um once a month
fine
a day of your time yeah and these are
things I need to know about okay cool
and what I want to speak to you about is
because I think you have this quite
naturally one set what should be on one
set yeah where's that come from
so you mentioned you've been around your
brother very much like stand up do it
again really yeah I think there's no
point dwelling on it is that there's no
point dwelling on it like you you're
lose a 10-grand deal in a day but you
might get another one later this
afternoon like it have you always had
that there cuz lot so when you have
really [ __ ] days you've got once did
what did what did you do how did you
just get a lot overcome that because
that doesn't I remember a lot of do at
24 K my first year so I've read a lot of
[ __ ] days is great but like there's so
many things that oh my god there's so
much rejection so much failure all that
sir and for me it was just perspective
and not nothing but not everyone has
that right so I'd walk into my office
and my colleague would be mine and the
traffic was terrible and that would ruin
their half of her day right whereas and
yeah like I said I could you could lose
a 5k deal and you could let that ruin
the rest your day or you could it
depends it's been out to take a step
back don't get me wrong like we all have
those days yeah of course we like with
caught off guard and something just does
really piss you off but I think it's
either one of two reasons either you
could have done something better in that
scenario and you did something wrong for
that to happen or [ __ ] happens it's just
the nature of the industry it's just
like bad luck yeah but did you take
response that you're talking about being
responsible and not everyone's
responsible the easy thing to do to
blend the candle and to blend the client
so where does that come from take a step
back and look at your own kind
actions where's that coming from I've
all I'm I've always been quite self
reflective really probably too much so
to be honest really yeah
you said you're a bit of an over-thinker
then yeah yeah okay how any lie okay
fair enough if that came quite natural
do you do anything to help that with
that self-reflection or is it literally
you just going round and round in your
head talking to yourself aloud you write
anything down totally see that
yeah but you write if it lies en fin how
with that self-reflection process like
for me I would make I would make time to
write stuff down and okay
yeah what's yoga helps you with just
having a break just chilling out I feel
like you'd find in quad to chill
obviously I so yeah I've done the yoga
for a while yeah and definitely helped
me yeah not just physically but mentally
and I guess I guess it does it does
cultivate being unsex that that doesn't
it and that that's the big thing life
you can get so wrapped up in yeah
emotions and what's going on it helps
you with that I think what I think stuff
that I can't like material things like
word deals go wrong or whatever I just
you know next thing etc I think what I
struggled in terms of mindset my last
company was just like office politics
well I think yeah like getting too
involved in the office politics and
everything else was going on in the
company and let that affected me much
more than the actual recruitment so me
taking a step back from that to doing it
myself I've removed all of that all I
need to think about now is like the
recruitment side of things and the
business side of things interesting
hmm okay where so I have there this
conversation quite a lot with people
where they set up on their own and I
guess there's a lot of people who wear
from day one now know that they want to
the business and there'll be people that
from day one they know that they want to
build they want to build a lifestyle
business if that's around a young family
or that that's just what they want right
and but from from the conversations I've
had and the people I speak to there's a
rule you can find yourself in a
difficult sport if you're in between
those those two places if in this is
this gonna be business or is it so have
you always known what happed ik is like
is it from day one when you convince
your brother right winging it are we
gonna do it we are you building the
business you building the business that
suits sort of you and your brother's
lifestyle what you want or what how do
you think of the business that way it's
a good question because it is it's
something I have asked myself a lot just
because I know you're young in the
journey and it might evolve but yeah
it's it's one point we did have to sit
down and make decision no because it
makes the decisions you know what that
is nothing but also the issue is is
because one of the main reasons I'm
doing this so we can do all the other
stuff you know be different build up a
brand do the events like all this other
stuff like we've been talking about like
doing like an app and things like that
whoa yeah so I can't do that that's a
lifestyle business do you not I mean
yeah yeah I need what is it like a
business so I can concentrate on all
that so yeah when I said someone I
always ask the direct question I was
like is this a lifestyle business is a
business because from from my standpoint
I need to know that from the marketing
services that I talked about and would
you what's your perception of a
lifestyle business just have interests
working having the freedom to work for
yourself on your own terms to have the
best life that that you want basically
hmm yourself really yeah this is really
you build a business around you and the
life that you want exactly we should say
business gives you that but when you're
thinking of a business you're thinking
about other people you think like that
and that all of a sudden then it's this
totally different ball game isn't it
yeah one of the key differences
obviously you're building something just
to potentially sell an X at one point
and the other one is it's just a
continuum it's how well your them
really yeah yeah it's nice interesting
cuz again I've had this conversation a
couple of times is like how often do
recruit members actually sell exactly
not quite sure especially if you there's
something we haven't quite worked out
especially if you do apart from the
conversation I'm no expert yeah I guess
I mean would that would that be a
problem if I was an investor if that
meant you guys were the go-to people in
the market not sure but from what I
understand the conversation I've had is
like or see if it's a perm business it's
like that is so real I'm like how are
you gonna how is the business going to
run if you're not there I mean we're
obviously from Wonderstone was a
contract book on business obviously
that's the great thing about having
recurring revenue in those things
obviously those relationships involved
however if that continues that's
something a lot more appetizing to an
investor because I mean that's what
contract is that Li yeah so we will
pivot because we didn't want to give any
investment any of our sorry any of our
share holding away so you you haven't
got any investment you know no we just
built it from the ground up and we want
to keep it that way
really so we need to do perm for a while
cash flow but then we will build up a
contracts division yeah I'm I sent so I
guess wasn't say how how old your
billion has been then since you started
because obviously there's so much other
[ __ ] now I know you got your little
categories see that that's all that's
also challenged isn't it because like
you've got these other categories you
don't think about now you're not just
employed than worried about pit fees on
the board you got your direct with
director duties how have you found that
how have you managed that but so I
obviously you could structure your day
the day that how have you managed that
and how's it could been with the billing
side so I'm not gonna lie when James
came on board that was a bit of a tricky
period because I had to invest so much
time into like James James yeah the
industry he'd never done perm
Oh Fox James didn't recruit in the
industry there previously
no oh yeah you really sold them the
dreams
literally was contracts teachers for
call it's completely different ballgame
ma yes I literally given the fact I've
never really trained any brighter
training money train him from scratch
and like run with it okay so obviously
yes for that two months wasn't great but
since then it's been it's been quite
consistent it's been okay
how have you managed out though would
you put that Nancy time management and
that's the hardest thing I've had to
overcome really because I'm all like
ideas daddy like to go on a tangent
exactly it's a time management and
processes is my like nemesis but I the
only way to succeed is that really so
I've had to master that and nothing
difficult I'm the key to that is that
the different four categories are stuff
yeah yeah okay so cut them all questions
and I'll let you go
what so I love the way that you just
yeah like your mindset towards being
different and all those things but like
what's your view on them
recruitment having a [ __ ] name like
white lion where do you see the how do
you see the recruiting industry changing
you've got the leaderboards as people at
the top miss people at the bottom
there's incentives there's all these
other things and if you're naturally
quite competitive and I was guilty of it
in cut corners you cut corners so I get
why it's got a bad name and I get why
does like so many stigmas attached to it
but you don't have to do that way hmm
and I guess and then is your is your
genuine approach like just just do the
right thing some fun like quite common
speakings people I think yes obviously
is the approach but I think people would
be lying if they said a hundred percent
of the time I do exactly the right thing
yeah sometimes you have to maybe give a
bit more influence or whatever no
obviously
yeah you understand yeah obviously you
do the right thing and you act in the
best interest of your candidates and
clients of course like that's the only
way you're gonna build up a community
build up a long-term Network and it's
only whether it's gonna separate you
from the others but yeah it can't it
can't happen like a thousand percent of
the time okay what what I wanted to I
didn't ask the question earlier but you
know you said they obviously got these
hubs in these different countries so how
how did you go about doing that because
like as I said like generally I'll have
them having so many conversations about
people and not just not just a service
in the UK market because it's so [ __ ]
saturating so how did you approach that
how does that happen because but you
only did Stockholm before right how did
you do that I think because I thought
and I what Stockholm then I did UK and
then when we did haptic I was like let's
think about our industry people are in
this Oren are in the industry for the
sheer love of what they do like they
absolutely love it and then the freedom
of movement is huge
so if you speak to someone in London who
have always want to work on this game
like they'd be playing in the whole
lives but that job is in Helsinki
they're much more likely to uproot their
lives and their family and moved to
Helsinki really yeah so I was thinking
well because there's so many relocations
anyway let's just dive in the deep end
and give people basically the option
let's give people so you did this you
did it free County okay yeah as in like
so yeah like I said you Speights that
person and they love that opportunity so
then you spent that person to these yeah
I don't I don't want to be limited okay
you can only move down the road in
London of course these hubs and this is
what the gaming space is like there so
did you pick up the phone and special
candidates need different places that's
it
yeah I did my it's all about market
mapping do your research understand your
industries know where the best companies
are and why and why people would want to
move there and how they gonna get there
and just kind of went from there really
mmm-hmm the longer-term
probably become some kind of like
relocation yeah advisory as well but you
can't do everything
yeah now that makes sense and so I'm
just trying to think because nobody
people listening would be like [ __ ]
out so what I'll just start be the in
like people need different obviously the
research parts if they identify yeah
like I said Barcelona is a really good
place for their mark here
you were saying literally so it's been
scanned of its spectrum in was that any
any any was any more than the normal
pushback from these businesses when you
were doing that whatever different
language just curious because like I
know you said the air is the same but a
lot of people they would easily make the
decision in the head before even trying
it it wasn't the same do you know I mean
know if someone's living there and
you're approaching that company to work
with them like Noah know about back yes
thanks know about that's yeah yeah
that's fun and also the selling point
you have is having this other network
elsewhere that you can then bring to
them yeah because if there's a candidate
shop market where they are shortage
where they are you have all these other
candidates yeah yeah totally
cool Warren sausage is our complete
curiosity was because you mentioned when
you first started before had to get your
laptop and had LinkedIn or whatever
light where where where you have the
most also know it's particular to your
niche but where do you get a lot of your
candidates like where there's a lot of
success for use at LinkedIn is it job
like probably not job boards but is it
put on your LinkedIn or really how am i
spoke about events last week like I know
you Lee she just made the meet up but
like any advice around that because
there'll be a lot of probably people
listening that I think I might setting
up events and stuff like through that
process will just jump in the deep end
did you learn anything about a good way
to structure or good way to sort
position it to why people should attend
and
those things like how did you go about
obviously do your research and what what
already exists yeah and what are the
gaps and get the right speakers people
you don't not gonna have to worry about
how many people turn up if you have the
right speakers they will come to you
so leverage yeah okay so identify people
that people would want to listen to it
and literally leverage that so I guess
from from the events I've been to in
some of the events we run here we've
really made sure that the people
attending and I put first because I
think that that's obviously always the
downfall from the marketing perspective
in the recruiters - like how we're gonna
make money from this Hannah and I think
I think they play like there's loads of
stats out there to back up the events
are like the best lead generators and
but I think the best way to do that
would be to really put your audience
first so and a big part of that would be
a get people that people may listen to
just like don't do like a hiring event
do something that is completely
irrelevant to recruit me yeah or your
mission do you do something that gives
back to the industry itself and people
in the longer term and indirectly will
give value right yeah yeah cool so
before we finish because I've spoke to a
few people about this new financial
challenge yeah so see you're based in we
work right now mm-hmm
how quickly do you get like an office or
I have a permanent des is a hot desk or
it's not this day one really from day
one yeah do you knew you needed that I
need somewhere to go and work that's
what I mean yeah I suppose a lot of
people where there might be they might
have that they made a space at home or
whatever and the one that can be really
lonely
yeah and challenges so has that really
it's difficult really but you found
basically just making the come in right
okay this is our office besides of C
Drive I'm going to head for work has it
given you anything but and if announced
besides being around other people and
that because all sit cut I know you've
got your brother but it can be quite
lonely right it's not [ __ ] it's just
meaning of all this [ __ ] like has it
helped with that as well I mean we work
as good it's like a sense of community
and they have loads of events it's like
networking excuse as well so you don't
miss his
that you might of before working the big
company that do loads about social
things yeah it's like that just didn't
it different yeah so it's just nice to
be know that it's not as you [ __ ]
slaving away exactly back garden yeah
okay cool
what am we excited about see your
podcast when's the next one coming out
next episode today so I did it with
someone used to work at your staff okay
who's also set up himself and it's aimed
at hiring managers and it basically
takes apart the whole process so whether
they're looking to use recruiters or
hire directly or whether it's like their
first employee in a start-up it talks to
anything from like taking a job spec
yeah I think it can't it make you just
how the recruitment process and why have
you done that I guess obviously the
obvious one is like brand etcetera
exactly but it does give you an excuse
to actually sit down and reanalyze it
and think about it and because as you
say I am basically a founder and we're
just like going 100 miles an hour I
don't have a lot of time to reflect and
especially because Kevin he's had a lot
of experience he's been internal etc
yeah so you feel like you got value too
yeah yeah cool like that so besides the
podcast then what's going on so I mean
big big big milestones hit also know
you're not quite the year mark yet but
that's that's also coming out which is
exciting but well what else you excited
about what's going on growing internally
that's what I'm excited about in London
we hitting America whoa touch words next
March really yeah
and how are you gonna go about doing
that you're gonna start placing business
from here first or you're gonna try and
tap something up to do it on the ground
there first so we're going to revolve it
around like a massive massive gaming
conference called GDC okay so we're
gonna basically in the run-up organize
meetings except to rhett and everyone's
gonna go
really yeah so what what as in you're
gonna start recruiting into America no
we're gonna well I don't know maybe
maybe not the new year but you want to
go over there to like client meetings
yeah oh cool
well that's all excited yes and they're
like events and just stuff like that
good all right well look before we
finish always like to ask one question
yes this question you can answer with a
phrase sentence anything okay the
question is if you could communicate to
every recruiter out there they would
listen to Hana Java so take on your
advice and start using your advice
tomorrow what springs to mind maybe a
couple of things okay first one don't
forget your personality yeah use it as
much as possible second one just do it
don't overthink it just do it if you
have an idea just do it and see what
happens and it's been a pleasure